se estaba viendo aquí en Argentina y
chile en Venezuela
que ya estaba en crisis antes del covid
nuestro trabajo
está en la segunda vuelta
[Música]
Voy a esperarme
a la gente que estuvo presente en la
sala a las personalidades
a las personalidades electorales que
estuvieron a cargo
el mensaje
es que Brasil
es de los más grandes de los países del
mundo
está saliendo la cuestión de la economía
también muestran un poco más lo que fue
la pandemia
Brasil compró 500 millones de vacunas
[Música]
en el deber de vacunarse tenemos datos
positivos
cuatro semanas
da para explicar bien a la población
nuestros resultados
ya ya
posibilidad
y existe la posibilidad bastante
avanzada de
conversarlo
Río de janeiros de nuestro partido
parece que el pelo el partido liberal
hizo una bancada de ciento y pocos
senadores
todos van a ser invitados a comenzar a
conversar con nosotros
durante la campaña porque es natural
que los candidatos se preocupen más de
su campaña que de la presidencial
entonces entiendo que
eso va a ayudarnos
a conseguir más apoyo para que ganemos
las elecciones
[Música]
no me da para tener todo eso en la
cabeza todavía
nuestro partido hizo ciento y un
diputados
bastantes
20% de la cámara eso es bastante en un
partido
está al frente para disputar cargos
públicos
sobre la mesa de negociación a partir de
ahora para la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones tenemos eso a nuestro favor
creo que se van a hacer buenas alianzas
yo no puedo hablar ahora mismo sobre eso
no es el nombre de todo el mundo chicos
conseguimos cerrado aquí
lo conseguimos en San Pablo
[Música]
Santa Catalina
Nosotros hemos crecido bastante
con las fuerzas aliadas a mí
y vamos a ver en estos días que faltan
antes de la segunda vuelta
confianza total
porque
yo creo que según las encuestas
dio el del 51 el treinta y poco a mí
eso ayuda
a aumentar las fuerzas del otro lado
A que no exista
yo creo que ahora ya no van a confiar en
esas encuestas claro como se equivocaron
debe ser el tío de pollo hablando allí
no no grito en calma por favor no grites
se ha educado señor
Vamos allá
inspito el sentimiento de la población
estamos un poco peor que la que antes de
la pandemia
y siempre el responsable pues es el jefe
del ejecutivo
solo que en esa segunda vuelta ahora
vamos a ver los cambios
que podemos ir a peor como en Argentina
Colombia Venezuela
escuche la economía
estamos en el tercer mes con
desinflación
por eso estamos en un nivel complicado
de prepandemia
el precio de los combustibles la
gasolina
bajo
llegó el primer navío de aceite de Rusia
bajo el precio también
vamos a ver es lo que pudimos hacer
después de tres a ocho meses después de
la pandemia
el mínimo de Brasil en 600 reales
violenciación de la violencia que hay a
la mitad
Entonces tenemos muchas cosas para
presentar y muchas mejoras
y también
lógicamente
tenemos el debate Tenemos que continuar
con eso
para que la gente para que podamos
convencer a las personas
yo quiero participar en él
tenemos
poco a poco no tenemos detalles todavía
Esta es la primera reunión después de
las elecciones
existe la posibilidad
vamos a hacer un buen trabajo hasta la
selección
existe por nuestra parte
conversamos
con interlocutores Entonces
vamos
a conversar
eso es reservado
días
las encuestas están desmoralizadas
en cualquier lugar del mundo que el
sistema no es 100%
siempre existe la posibilidad de que eso
pase
con un sistema totalmente informado
yo dije en el senado
verdad
resolvió
pero era la idea
Michelle le apareció
20 años que trabaja en la cámara
y es el reflejo de ese buen trabajo lo
que ha conseguido hoy
a diferencia del nordeste
el resultado del primer turno 2018
esa votación ha perdido es la que
tenemos que recuperar
lo recibí por teléfono pero estoy
esperando
para que recuperemos el voto perdido
y sabemos que los candidatos al gobierno
están un poquito más abajo de lo normal
casi todos los estados
han bajado en las elecciones para
presidente
en cuanto a los impuestos federales
nada para disminuirlos
un 17% se disminuyó
no se puede disminuir más no podemos
disminuirlos más
hemos disminuido poco pero pero sí que
hemos disminuido algo
[Música]
el sentimiento de las personas
se pusieron
vamos a mostrarles a esas personas con
más énfasis
que la economía se está recuperando a
pesar de los altibajos
y que necesitamos un poco de tiempo para
arreglarlo
y demostrar que las cosas no siempre van
a mejor que pueden empeorarlo
y el cambio a la izquierda es el ejemplo
de lo que pasa aquí en América del Sur
por Petro
Todos esos países empeoraron y Su
economía también en Argentina
el 40% de la población está en la línea
de la pobreza
el precio de los productos agrícolas
El ladrón negocio
ese momento difícil
en casa yo fui contra la política de
quedes en casa
ya saben mi opinión sobre todas esas
cosas
pero algunos cambios se fueron
cercanías
pero la cuestión de TV
resolví
En tercer lugar él estaba en tercer
lugar
qué aumentó su popularidad
a partir de ahora nuestra querida prensa
tendenciosa y les gusta inclinarse por
la izquierda y decir maravillas
pero yo creo que el trabajo de Nicolas
ayudar a los jóvenes a votar
correctamente en el segundo turno
no tengo la seguridad para hablar aquí
una frase que la había hablado sobre
Parece que fue eso
va a haber segunda vuelta así que bueno
ustedes ya saben que una palabra
incorrecta y se va afuera
28 años de diputado tres de presidente
uno ocurre nada
comprendida o explorada por ustedes de
forma negativa
me preocupo que Brasil perdió su
libertad
Brasil
camina hacia la izquierda
por los caminos de Venezuela de la
Argentina Colombia
y también chile en Nicaragua Esa es mi
preocupación
la primera víctima es la libertad del
pueblo
yo creo que sus electores son mucho más
simpáticos hacia mí
y ellos saben que tenemos elecciones
las más importantes de Brasil
experimenta que volver atrás no es fácil
tenemos que ganar por su libertad por la
democracia
la libertad de culto el respeto a la
familia
la legítima defensa y por otro lado la
negación de todo eso
el respeto a la familia
la legalización de ciertas cosas que los
padres no desean para sus hijos
volver
a recursos para dictaduras exteriores
mucha gente del área urbana
quiere pedir 500 tierras indígenas
nuevas
y nosotros acabaríamos con el agro
negocio la seguridad alimentaria
[Música]
luna también
cobrar una tasa de los trabajadores
para el sindicato Entonces tenemos que
demostrar que todo eso
solo vamos a perder no tenemos nada que
ganar si vamos por ese camino
[Música]
escuche mi elección
es muy inteligente
los enemigos rápidamente
Porque algunos de ellos pidieron ciertas
cosas que
esa persona que está llegando ahora
ya ha visto como el gobierno ha
funcionado
mucho
a probar ciertas medidas
como la reforma tributaria por ejemplo
después de las elecciones tenemos que
ver claro no vamos a hablar ahora de
propuestas
por una posible reelección
dos plazas
en el supremo
ya empieza a hacer valer nuestras
propuestas
pero infelizmente
la agricultura
intensamente
está completamente cerrada esa propuesta
el punto más importante fue sobre el
protocolo de tratamiento de
él tenía unos tratamientos para combatir
la malaria
Por qué no da la libertad para recetar
todos esos remedios y medicinas
y él no tuvo una respuesta para mí un
punto muy importante
que sirvió para tomar una decisión sobre
él
es muy bienvenido
mucha más tranquilidad para nosotros
participar efectivamente la composición
de la mesa
allá atrás en la historia
para lavar sus manos
sobre lo que hizo
que vayan a la prisión por un lado a
otro
peor que una decisión mal tomada
eso es lo que se aprende la carrera
militar
tiene que saber aceptar la derrota y
salir